first thing get your hand down here
yeah the originator of the ufc
but mohi ahmed did not have the 1 000
the man was demanding for repairs and he
said that i'm going to kill him now
then i said no you are not touching my
son and then immediately he hit me one
right hook so you don't drink alcohol
pork i don't eat pork you don't eat pork
foreign
[Music]
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dichotomy of your host
how are you doing how are you doing
as always i have
an exciting program for you guys here on
the dean show we have
the grand master horry and gracie this
is the originator the founder of the ufc
so those that have been watching khabib
and other greats hois gracie of the
gracie family he's a ninth degree black
belt
he's the father of hiron henner uh the
brother of hixson hoyce uh helsin hulker
uh we got him here
how are you horin
amazing how are you thank you for the
opportunity good good i i i wanna
black belt was a long time ago no no i
mean red belt 9th degree
sorry about that
i had a lot to get in there and i forgot
to mention probably over a span of over
10 years
has probably had more challenge matches
than most people in the family and so
for those who are wondering what are
these challenge matches since most
martial arts focus primarily in punching
and kicking
flexibility
power and speed
are absolute prerequisites for those
arts
so this is you now right
okay
then as soon as i go what's he doing
here he's got a nice warm-up going on
huh
he even tries to reach for my groin i
had countless of this kind of matches
not only at the place like this when you
have pedal communal college in
california
but also people come to the garage and
bring instructors and stuff the martial
arts show comparison
yes you know
and the great are pretty much the same
so this is you now this is a this is a
hub keto black belt
yes
so he goes through this not once twice
but
he he couldn't wrap his mind around
things huh
which is kind of an understandable
position you know this actually happened
three times in a row uh a person who's
been training you know a striking art
for a long time
you know 10 15 20 years in front of a
mirror or in a school within the frame
of mind of staying at a certain distance
and trying to you know hit your opponent
with a specific punch or a kick
it's hard for them to call you know to
conceive
that in a real fight it's it's more than
that
now people are realizing nowadays that a
fight gets in the clinch real quick and
it goes to the ground or you know the
whole thing is not exactly what they
hoped for within the limitation of rules
so what these people had
him and many others were just a wake-up
call to say hey
i can't expect my opponent to do what i
want him to do you know he's going to do
what he wants to do and my goal and
anybody else who does grappling is to
grab the opponent take him to the ground
where he's out of his punching kicking
ability and then hopefully pick the guy
for submission that's the idea this is a
pretty big crowd here
um yeah you know every time you
announced one of those matches they kind
of kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger which eventually led to the
to the ufc you know okay and what did
the times we did this the more
interesting people showed up and then
again the crowds will keep getting
bigger and i said we have to show this
to the world
and that's what led to the creation of
the show yeah so last time we had you on
the program you were giving us some good
advice for
some proper nutrition eating uh with the
gracie diet for ramadan
that's right you remember that right
yeah i remember that of course this took
it right here guys yeah that's what it's
at and i follow the combination of the
greasy diet and just change the life of
the better how was the feedback did you
get some feedback from when we uh last
got together
there's always people that try for the
first time they don't want to you know
they think their word diet is very you
know has a restrictive connotation to it
but i remind them that there's not a
diet that you can't eat anything you
practically can eat anything you want as
long as you combine the foods properly
that's the idea and the whole idea
behind the concept of food combining is
to avoid blood acidity and keep your
your body alkaline which is you know
avoiding
degenerative and contagious disease
that's the idea if you can stay your
body alkaline you're protected
especially nowadays now with this whole
thing going on everybody concerned about
keeping a strong immune system and so
forth
uh the best thing you can do is let your
health come you know strong from within
i i want to talk about some different
things i mean i'm just going to have a
summary because uh you um
for people that don't know you have a
very unique history you know you were in
the grind you know someone who came over
here in the 70s if that correct me if
i'm ever wrong you know multiple times
and then teaching and doing many of
these uh you you attained your law
degree back in
brazil came over here you were at a ymca
one time and then you ended up
you know leaving your money in your
documents and then ended up getting
stolen
right and then you prolonged your trip
for seven months for six months you know
and um ended up actually on the street
for some time pant you know begging for
for money working as a dishwasher clean
i mean you just been through so much you
know it didn't
you didn't get to where you were easily
you know you were in the grind
you didn't give up though you didn't
give up
well that's the whole idea is that
everybody has problems you know life is
about problems the question is how you
deal with that there's no such a thing
that having a life just a bed of roses
that you have nothing to worry about no
concerns it's not yet and i learned very
early on in my life that all bad things
happen for a good reason
so i i welcome you know uncertainty and
not being quite sure exactly what's
going to happen that's almost a you know
i feel i'm not comfortable in that kind
of a state of mind you know
not having guaranteed everything
and that had made made it possible for
me to try some things that are you know
potentially very wild and crazy and oh
my gosh it's not going to work and i
tried i tried before you know it's
happening and it would be life would
have been very different if i didn't
feel confident that even under a very
stressful situation there's always
something that we can do that can turn
things around people that are not
willing to take a chance they're not
really going to do much and you know
like the saying goes if you want to take
over the island you better seek the boat
you came in so that's what it takes you
know i came here determined to make it
happen and the result is that we
ultimately change the world
tell me i want to do something different
here i want to do some breakdowns with
you
watch some uh some videos and get your
perspective uh but before that you also
just going into what you said there's a
lot of wisdom in some of the things that
you talk about and experiences and some
stories one was uh if you can share with
us it stood out with me when you were
remodeling the academy down there and
you needed this uh beam
for the uh
and then
the people who are gonna be doing the
stucco or whatever they gave you a
timeline set of tomorrow or the next day
and then you ended up in home depot and
you needed this one part
but the moral of the story you could
take it from here was that you had
always this faith you know what i mean
and you had this belief that things
happened for a reason you know what i
mean like there was a higher power the
creator you know watching over and
you're it's like you were making i'm
sure within yourself these prayers and
god like answered them you know you had
faith
that's i mean ultimately that's what it
comes down to you know is that uh you
have to believe i you know we're just
little grains of sand
you know throughout this the whole
world that we live in and i'm i have no
doubt at least i'm very convinced
strong believer that there is something
up there people call it god or you know
whatever you want to call it
um you know whatever but the bottom line
is that there's something over there
that runs the universe and that
that story that you mentioned that i
really i needed a specific uh support
like a metal support to fix a beam
at the new academy you know the guy was
going to come in the next day to put
this stuff so i had to have that done
so uh i went to home depot
and i asked for the lady i need
something like this you know a specific
size she said we don't carry that size
we only have the little small size which
is you know for a whole news and stuff
like that that's that industrial side
what you're looking for
and i said where's the aisle that you
keep the little home side stuff she said
well aisle eight whatever so i went to
isle 8 and i looked around and as i'm
looking around i find one which is
exactly what i wanted you know the
industrial side
and i brought it to the front desk and
said hey listen ladies you said i didn't
have it but i found one
she said well we don't sell this i don't
know what it's doing back there in fact
she run the barcode scanner thing and
she scanned the little thing on the side
of it she said [__] it's not even from
this shop i can't sell it's not it
doesn't go to home depot somebody must
left it over there
i mean i can't even charge you for it
take it home so i took it with me for
free
something that if you go any other home
depot at the time they wouldn't have it
now they probably have in the stock but
at the time they didn't have it bottom
line is she didn't charge me for it i
found exactly the one piece i needed
inside of a shop like home depot to
finish the job that day so the next
morning this stucco people could come in
and finish the front of the whole
building in other words if that little
some piece wasn't there it would be in a
mess but like you said you know every
time i take a step on doing something in
my life i come in with a lot of faith
that something is going to happen
there's something watching over me and
that you know it has happened i've
learned to count on that kind of help
how's that
and it's fascinating how it works it's
just amazing here's uh let's get into
some of these videos and your reactions
so we know how important the headlock
escape is you have variations from the
top to the bottom
and
let's get into uh your comments and
thoughts on this this headlock
i keep popping on my neck yeah hand him
here pull
pull see difficult yeah
first thing get your hand around here
yeah
and control your hands here's your hand
i can drop yeah because if i let this
hand go yeah you might coming into smack
in the face yeah you see what i mean
yeah so this hand i grabbed your thumb
here yeah yeah and i'm here
now it falls into the slide here yeah
okay so now uh difficult for you to move
now
you see the idea yeah what happened
there then tell them what happened here
you squeeze my thumb against the
nail so when i talk about thing all the
time yeah because we're in the outside
woodwind headlock no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no go slowly
man
so i gotta put his hand inside it's
sweetheart yeah yeah and when i do this
you reaction see my hand now for your
thumb okay i will paint this closest to
here
yeah so when i think in here i want full
size see like here now yeah so uh this
is in case you try to find me back if
you find me back as you see i force it
into here to make sure you're in pain
yeah yeah i hold this hand tight so
difficult for you to hurt me now if
someone has seen them seen it at all
you've seen it all you've you've you've
went away you've you've won against all
different grand masters in hakido aquido
kung fu and whatnot and you've battle
tested you know that was the whole thing
of the usc battle testing not just in
theory how many people have those
conversations well my style your style
his style but come on it's a science
behind the jiu jitsu the gracie jiu
jitsu there's a science behind because
it was battle tested what do you think
of uh when you see uh
this kind of what do you uh what are
your thoughts your reactions
well you know
he's presenting one way in a
circumstance that you know made it
possible to work i mean he's gonna do
what he thinks works ultimately for me
is uh like you said is battle tested you
know the gracie jiu-jitsu brazilian jiu
jitsu that we practice have been done
over and over for generations and have
the results that we see today the whole
world has embraced that the question of
the person who demonstrated a technique
like that to see if it works for him
great how would that work in a real
fight you know against someone who's
you know bigger heavy and stronger
swinging punch than him is that we have
to one way to find out is to go in there
and do it have you seen have you been in
situations where you have people who
they're they're mesmerizing you know
people where they'll throw some kind of
you know um force energy the guy people
their students will fall to the floor
and whatnot and then have you gone up
against people like this and just
dismantled and just put everybody's you
know people who maybe they're sincere
some people it's a gimmick you know and
a lot of people sadly they end up
developing this false sense of security
and that's what we want to try to avoid
you want to make sure if you're training
the martial art that it's going to
really be able to benefit you if you're
attacked if you're in a life-threatening
situation you don't want to train for
20-30 years and then everything goes to
waste you know false sense of confidence
of the art well
my idea was not to destroy people's
self-confidence you know that was never
the intent yeah i've had you know dozens
and hundreds of people come to the
garage back in the day
because they couldn't believe you know
when their students start telling hey i
don't want to train you just instead of
training this martial art with you
they're going to say hey i'm i'm gonna
fight this youtube guy so they'll bring
the instructors to the academy i mean to
the garage and we had a chance to spar
with hundreds of people in a very humane
way you know like i said most of the
time the people that came to fight to
try to beat me up were so impressed with
the simplicity and the effectiveness
that jiu jitsu would allow me to have to
overcome and control the situation those
guys said i need to learn this and a
lots and lots and lots of them became
students and friends and supporters of
the whole thing nothing against all
martial arts if it works for you great
the bottom line is
you have to think in terms of how would
that fare in an actual street fight if
you have a technique that works great
the reason i created the ufc to make
that very clear
it was so the people could compare
different styles of martial arts the
very first ufc's if you recall
they were specifically i'll pick
different representatives of different
styles
on the octagon
close the gate and say do whatever you
want
two guys walk in one guy walks out
that's that's how he makes it work so
ultimately
crazy brazilian jiu jitsu prevail in
such a way that nobody goes into the ufc
today at least having an idea of some
basics of grappling if you don't you
don't have a chance so my mission was
accomplished when i was able to convey
the message that you need to know how to
fight on the ground and that's why the
whole idea you know came about and i was
fortunately very successful at
demonstrating that made a point of it
and
voice goes in there the smallest light
is gonna determine and shows everybody
else how it's done
let's go into uh this next video
after his car was clipped saturday night
here in jackson heights this is an
accident accidents do happen calm down
i'll give you whatever you need to to
get i said okay pay me up now i need
money right now but mohia med did not
have the one thousand dollars the man
was demanding for repairs and he said
that i'm going to kill him now
then i said no you are not touching my
son and then immediately he hit me one
right hook mohi's son adele watched his
father fall to the ground here on 70th
street and i've never seen my dad
knocked out and put in such a
humiliating way like this never
you know and i just
did the loudest deal that i could
possibly do i just like i was so loud
but i wanted to cry i
couldn't a woman was with the guy in the
sweatshirt she tried to stop him but
then watch as he goes after adele at
that point you know i think you saw i
was kind of in a prone position so i
just kind of did this and you know
i was just i could hear you know pound
pound pound police say the attacker took
their phones and wallet but me i was
just shaking on control i don't want
anybody else to go through it because
the guy he did it to me he will do it to
somebody else maybe next time it will be
worse and while the welts are starting
to heal the emotional wounds are raw i
was embarrassed
that i couldn't do anything to protect
my father
that this man just trampled you know on
our dignity that was really sad to see
what are your reactions now
uh when you see something could this if
someone was trained you know a level of
blue belt
if you knew
you know
absolutely no way
that that would have happened you'll
definitely have the elements to control
his opponent that's number one
uh unfortunately we live in a world that
is you know getting crazier and crazier
by the minute and people like that are
not going to disappear aggressors and
attackers like that criminals should be
punished you know to the full extent of
the law but sometimes you just can't
expect somebody to be protected all the
time that is the importance of knowing
how to defend yourself this man should
learn final place where he can learn to
defend himself and practice that
and that would be good for him give
himself confidence and the ability to
defend himself but ultimately you just
don't count on people being around to
protect you you have to know how to do
it yourself
and again
those hoodlums are going to be around
forever it's part of life
so
yeah it just has me thinking just you
know because a lot of people train uh
jiu jitsu but uh the butterfly guard and
other things which i mean it's effective
when you're playing sports jujitsu but
just knowing
the core elements of gracie brazilian
jiu jitsu is what we teach at our
academy also and this is what the gracie
system is about uh is teaching you how
to defend yourself in these situations
absolutely the idea of jujitsu has
always been
prepare you to defend yourself it's
ultimately it's a self-defense system so
yes the best you know so if you're just
gonna see the supportive aspect of
jiu-jitsu which is really good nothing
wrong you know how to you know spawn on
the ground and roll around and stuff
like that it's great but sometimes
what happens is an individual goes into
a school where the focus for example is
sportive shoeships right so the guy's
training up goes up in the racks you
know blue purple brown eventually gets a
black belt wins a tournament as a black
male and because he was able to hold a
certain position he gets an advantage
and now he wins the
tournament and now he's got a black belt
and now he owes up opening up by school
he opens up the school and he's going to
teach what he knows which is the same
concept at this point we should do this
alone
depriving his students from learning the
ultimate program of self-defense which
is basically the idea behind jiu-jitsu
to begin with
so because the focus is going to be just
on the sparring aspect of it and the
sporting aspect of it the students will
never have the opportunity to learn
something that could protect them in a
real life situation
that is a problem
and in fact
this book here that my father did called
gracie jiu-jitsu which is now available
it's not available this is the second
the revised vision
editions it's uh you know you're doing a
special
sale on the book if you go to amazon you
can find it over there for a special
price 25 dollars off
covers all these stand up techniques
exactly the stuff you're talking about
which is the moves like this that shows
you what to do in different
circumstances
that if you get
you know finding yourself in different
positions no matter what that is
and it covers all the different
possibilities like different attacks and
stuff like that this is the original
self-defense program that my father
developed back in the 50s for the
original race academy in brazil and so
forth
so i highly recommend that you practice
not only this kind of techniques but
find a school where self-defense is the
focus you know that's the idea
i saw one time a video and and this is
how just stressing how important it is
like basic things like headlock escape
because someone can go ahead and hold
your head and just by knowing the proper
technique of turning in towards the
person instead of a way because i saw a
video where someone was
was choking someone and the person turns
their head opposite and what happens
they end up in a choke now
and the person ended up going
unconscious and now the person who's
holding it he doesn't know to let go and
he continues to hold so only god knows
if he ended up you know brain damaged
kill the guy but if you know just from a
few class one class that you end up
going to and you learn the techniques
you know from that class that can be
applied right away if something was to
go down
absolutely can make all the difference
knowing what to do and not knowing makes
all the difference you know down the
street you don't have to turn left or
right you know you go left goes to one
place you go right to go in another
direction so having a little bit of
knowledge and this program was devised
to teach you the whole general concept
in like 36 classes it's basically it's
all you need you know and if you get the
basics on that no matter what situation
you find yourself in eventually at least
you have an idea of which way to go it
makes a huge difference now somebody
asked what do you do in this situation
jorian this is now a woman
and what was your reaction to something
like this now
a violent carjacking at a gas station in
northwest houston all of this caught on
camera yeah thieves attacked and they
robbed a woman there the good news is
police found her car and they have that
surveillance video right there that may
help track down these guys chris costa
is live with more on how to stay safe in
these kind of situations and avoid
becoming a victim chris
yeah resin reca crime stoppers of
houston say these types of robberies
happen all the time almost every day the
good news for that woman those security
cameras got a clear look at the
suspect's faces
the moment a woman is attacked gets
caught on camera two men confront a
woman at a gas station in the middle of
the night the cameras at the station get
a clear look at their faces one man
grabs the woman she immediately tries to
take a swipe to protect herself to keep
them off of her the other starts going
through her truck the woman fights back
kicking at her attacker until they both
take off stealing her truck really sad
to see and it's interesting he said they
happen every day what someone says look
how's gracie jutsu going to benefit me
there
well
number one is her safety it's important
that you understand that
two
males attacking one woman
there's a very good chance that she
could get very seriously injured you
could be armed or not endless
possibilities
so by her getting away from the guy
which is a smart thing to do is one
thing she also you know as you saw she
was on the ground using the feet to keep
the guy away which is a you know one way
to keep the distance she did what she
could in there assuming that she didn't
know anything but you can't expect a
woman to learn self-defense and go out
and hunt and beat guys up that's not the
idea the idea is to defend yourself i
think she was very lucky
that uh they you know just took whatever
she could took the truck and got away
lucky that she was in a situation that
was well lit and the cameras caught the
bad guys i guess criminals and hoodlums
are going to be attacking people all the
time it's up to you to have at least a
little bit of a basic knowledge of what
to do so you can increase your chance of
success and hopefully getting away
safely and unharmed
yeah that's what i often tell my
students is i mean now you're equipped
you know to have a little more
confidence you know to deal with some
situations so at least you can get
yourself out and you can and if not to
go and
if you don't need to fight you can flee
at least you can get out you know
instead of being totally vulnerable
yeah
and this is what we see like uh your
your father
um carlos gracie helio gracie you know
the the system that was developed it was
about survival it's about you know a
small person being able to
fight off and survive against someone
who is much larger stronger
dominant
and we see your father you know fighting
for like three hours and 40 minutes in
some yes
the idea if you don't if you know a
woman like that for example being able
to go home she won
yeah
if you see a cheetah chasing the little
deer if the deer escapes he won he
doesn't have to go there
as long as he goes home that night he
did all right
i remember
you were talking about this love and
reverence that
helio had for carlos carlos for helio
they were you know uh they also
between the two had 30 kids
yes yeah
and uh tell us any stories that come to
mind you know from i know your father at
one time he actually saved someone from
a ship right someone was uh he jumped
off the ship to bring them in
yeah the guy they were going from
northern brazil on a ship north of
brazil to rio and halfway down the coast
the passenger you know goes into the
water
nobody knew at the time but the guy was
trying to commit suicide that's how he
got in there yeah but then they see a
guy floating on the water and everybody
sees that eventually the captain sends a
boat with five sailors to rescue the man
and the guys by you know a couple
hundred yards away from the ship by the
time they got to him and the man was so
weak that every time the little boat the
tides were going very you know up and
down and every time the little boat got
close to him it would get out grip on
the man the tide would lift up the boat
and they would lose grip on the guy and
they tried that over and over over
several times
my father who was on the deck of the
ship thinking out loud said how come
somebody from the little boat does not
jump in the water so they can help the
guy up because the man is obviously too
weak he can barely keep himself afloat
and uh a sailor behind him said this is
ambrose thinking that my father knew
what ambrose meant
and my dad had no idea abroad happens to
be one of the highest concentration of
sharks on the atlantic ocean there yeah
abroad reef on the coast of brazil so
what the guy meant is they're not going
in because there's this is sharp land
you know
anyways my father not knowing that
uh just watching like everybody else's
situation until the captain signals to
the guys on the boat
to relieve i mean to let the guy leave
the man behind and roll back to the ship
so now the sailors are rolling back to
the ship after leaving the guy behind
the middle of the ocean so at that point
my father turned to his brother carlos
said that man is going to be left to die
you know do you want to go save the guy
uncle carlos said i can't make it
and my father said i think i can't he
said go for it. so my dad down stripped
down his clothes and you know do his
drugs or whatever and then jumps off the
ship
he said when he was airborne he thought
what if there are sharks
you can't rewind that button so he went
flat on his tummy swimming towards the
guy as a little boat is returning to the
ship he say let's go back and they turn
around they all go back to where the man
is
and ultimately he is in the water with
the guy helps the guy out and put him on
the little boat and they bring the guy
back to the ship and so forth
and
when he returns to the ship uh they you
know hoist the boat up
and then everything is resolved and my
father is ultimately called into the
captain's quarters
the captain want to talk to him
and he said captain i'm sorry i said mr
grayson don't say anything
send the captain to him let me tell you
something if my mother had come to visit
me here in this region in this area
and on getting out of the boat to step
into the ship she fell in the water and
her life would depend on me
fishing her out of the water with my
foot
i wouldn't do it for my mother so what
you did is nothing to apologize for
congratulations thank you very much by
the whole thing to a big party for me on
the ship and stuff like that was good
many years later i asked my dad dad were
you afraid
he said i was absolutely petrified when
he jumped he said i was so scared
that i was swimming as fast as i could
to get to the man
so that if shark shoulder a shark showed
up he would have a choice of biting him
instead of biting me that's how scared i
was
so ultimately
feeling fear is only a natural thing of
course especially under the
circumstances but i want to i want to
bring the attention here to our
listeners that fear is part of life you
know to be afraid of a certain situation
here's a it's a defense mechanism that
wants to protect you
anybody who says i'm not afraid of
anything i'll do anything that's an
inconsequent person
it's not that he's not afraid he's just
not thinking straight he's not very
bright you have to measure your chance
of success to jump on the water that
potentially shark infested water is
something that you should be afraid of
you're going to say however what my
father saw in circumstance was that he
saw his mission
as something bigger
than his fear
so for him
the idea of seeing a man drowned to
death
it was not
he couldn't accept that he said if i can
i'm going to try to help that guy so he
jumped was swimming like i said very
very scared got to the man and did put
the guy in one inside the help to put
the guy in the boat and save the guy's
life again he embraced his fear as
something bigger you know i mean his
mission is something bigger than his
fear so this is what we have to do
sometimes we find ourselves in a very
difficult spot and you have to kind of
be able to to understand that you know
prioritize yourself and see if it's
something that you should be you know
pushing as hard as you can with your
life behind it and so forth
but fear is just part of the deal don't
expect to live without fear because
that's not going to happen once again
we're with
the innovator the founder the originator
of
the ufc
the one who started it all
9th degree red belt
grand master
hori and gracie uh this was before dana
white where was dana white at that time
i don't know
before him he did a great job promoting
the thing yeah i must take my hat the
guy did an amazing job amazing to make
it yeah one of the biggest you know if
not the fastest growing sport in the
world very popular top of the place i'm
very happy that it was a good transition
one time i was having dinner with him
and i said hey i feel like i followed
the baby you adopted the child sent him
to harvard now the kid is running wall
street
you know yeah but many people don't know
that this was before dana before the the
the two brothers this is way
yeah this is the
the original you know when it all
started yeah
and you were doing all these even before
the ufc i mean these challenge matches
that that were happening you know to
prove without a doubt that gracie jutsu
is the most effective martial art not
just by theory but actually this was a
science it was battle tested and then
you went above and beyond and you
started also
to um bring back to light something that
carlos gracie was really adamant about
about nutrition and the last time i
remember i'll never forget i used i
still use this a lot when i'm talking
about one of my favorite subjects uh
nutrition
is how people are managing the symptoms
and not going to the root of the problem
and strengthening the immune system and
you made an example it's just like the
check engine light that comes on and you
put a band-aid over it that's right
i got that from you you remember that
and then take off with this take off
with this you said the world champion
who cannot beat
his desire for ice cream
uh you know this is a big problem
talk about this
well ultimately you know for you to be
successful at anything one of the strong
ingredients
is discipline discipline yeah to self
listen to have the willpower to do what
it takes if you want to be to succeed
and excel and to go beyond everything
it's going to require that you have
certain qualities you know the willpower
the self-control the discipline to do
that is really important
and uh if you want to be healthy you
have to study it the same way you learn
you know you want to be an engineer you
have to study engineering and if you
want to be a doctor or a teacher
whatever pianist you have to study that
subject and most people
learn to eat great grandmother teaches
grandma grandma teaches mom mom teaches
us and we're going to teach our kids
what we like to eat
for most people the pleasure the flavor
becomes the determining factor why you
eat something then you don't eat other
things i like it i eat it i don't like
it i don't eat it
but like just because you like it
doesn't mean it's good for you
the trick is to learn to like the things
that are good for you that's the secret
it's easy for you to develop the habits
for something that's not you know but
good for your health so the secret for
failure
is a few bad habits repeated every day
you keep doing the same thing over and
over you know eventually you have to pay
that bill you know it's going to have to
catch up with you you can't assume that
you keep doing something wrong over and
over and over it's going to catch up
with you
well the same way the secret for you
know the formula for failure is to
repeat the same bad habits every single
day
the formula for success is to embrace
new healthy habits little by little keep
changing you have to rearrange your life
so you have to choose the right thing
you know we're here to grow and to
spiritually mature and evolve and so
forth you can't you're not here just to
eat wake up in the morning have
breakfast you're going to say and then
go to work and make a paycheck go to the
bathroom and go to sleep at night and
just that's not it
we have to grow more than anything the
spiritual aspect of our life
and uh
the food the discipline of learning to
eat the right thing is very important
when i was five years old i would go to
birthday parties with my brothers and
when we get there the fathers of the
kids would cut a piece of you know
chocolate cake or whatever give it to
everybody a piece of cake they say no
thank you very much it's not my time to
eat
you know i have a five-year-old kid
telling an adult it's not my time to eat
thank you very much you called my dad i
said hey what's going on the kids here
at the birthday party not eating the
cakes it's not it's time to eat
and my father had to explain that we
have a certain diet and we eat certain
things we just went there to party and
play with the kids but don't worry about
us as far as feeding us
of course my dad was wise enough to feed
us dinner before we went to the party so
they would not be hungry looking at a
piece of chocolate cake wanting to eat
that but right everybody say you know
four words you know just went there to
play literally
and uh for us the concept of learning
how to eat properly
was much more than just the food
combination was the fact that we
developed a level of discipline
that would serve us in different aspects
of our life
when you as we talked about last time
was right before ramadan you know why
don't you know why do you why do you do
that why do you obey that concept why
can't you just go home by yourself and
just say there's nobody at home i'm
going to stop myself at noon because you
know this is not where it's at you have
to respect certain things you have to
look at yourself in the mirror and say
i'm doing the right thing so the same
thing for us was for me or for the
family was the concept of the diet we
eat certain things we don't mix certain
things there's a certain guideline and
i'm 70 years old to be 70 in a couple of
months i feel great and if i have never
had a cavity in my life wow my body
works i don't take medicine for anything
i'm 70 years old every guy after 50 is
taking five kills a day you know what
i'm saying
everything works fine the way it should
my my clothes size that i wear today is
the same thing i was wearing 25 50 years
ago when i was 25 years old so the
bottom line is that it pays off to be
healthy
in the long run i think i mentioned to
you the last time i saw my dad
i went to visit the old man on his ranch
in brazil
six months before he passed away he was
94 and a half i went to visit the old
man
and when i get there he gives me a kiss
and say holy let's go in the mat i want
to show a new choke i'm working on at 94
kick my butt i mean that's the way life
should be you live as long as you're
young and then you die you're gonna sing
because
all of us we know people that we love
dearly and as they get older they start
deteriorating and getting weaker and
sick and just kind of
the whole thing is not falling out
it's sad and unfortunately for them
going through that kind of painful
sometimes experience and for us there's
not much we can do to watch a lot of
person just kind of you know deteriorate
and just kind of define weight it's not
good
my dad was different he lived like this
for a long time you know and then we
went away one day just gone that's the
way it should be you know that's the way
it should be
for all of us but if you don't invest on
your health now
it's it's gonna be one of those that
just goes like a little bit getting
worse by the and that's not good that's
not healthy
you know my my theory is that you have
to seriously consider how do you want to
spend the last 10 years of your life
do you want to spend 10 years you know
joyfully enjoying playing with your
children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren you know rolling
around visiting you know traveling and
having fun
and then when wait then you wake up and
say i'm out of here like my father did
or do you want to just getting sicker
and sicker and getting worse and all
kinds of health problems that's not it
that's not what it's at
i'm living proof that this grace and
that stuff works the combination pays
off the couch spent 65 years 16 food
combined wow and he was not a doctor he
just did research on his own came up
with some amazing conclusions on how you
should combine your food and if you
don't mind i'll give you a quick break
down here two minutes yes please number
one
number one we do not mix
starches when i eat bread i don't eat
potato
if i eat rice i don't eat beans
everybody in brazil is rising b
i don't
so it's the fact that everybody else is
doing is out of ignorance they're not
sure exactly why and why not they just
developed the habit of doing it so we
don't mix starches okay it's better to
have two hamburgers than having one
hamburger and one french fries
because the bread and the potato are
different starches should not be mixed
with the same meal i can have the rice
and i can have the beans but not rice
and beans together that's the idea so
that's rule number one number two when
we eat food like cooked food that is
prepared with oil or butter or fat of
any kind we do not eat sugar in other
words after you have a meal that you
have you know fish or chicken and
vegetables and pasta for example you
don't want to have fruits you don't want
to have a bowl of ice cream or a piece
of cake for dessert there's no dessert
because they usually have sugar and
sugar with the fat that the food was
prepared with is not a good healthy
combination for you so no dessert two
reasons number one you're not hungry
after you have a meal you usually are
not hungry you just like a little sweet
because it tastes good that five minute
of pleasure there has long time negative
consequences on your health if you do
that for a long time not good for you so
take me up you know trust me on that and
rule number three
is that you must wait for one meal to
digest completely
before you eat a second meal in other
words if you have a meal at eight
o'clock in the morning you have to wait
at least four and a half to five hours
until you eat the next meal there's no
such a thing as snacks in between meals
we don't have a break breakfast is 8
o'clock in the morning and then at 10 30
11 o'clock you have a fruit or you know
a little cookie or a cup of coffee and
then a couple hours later you eat lunch
no such a thing how about liquids what
about something like liquids
only water
only one
fresh coconut water or regular water how
about water with lemon with lemon and
honey no no no no
absolutely not no
in fact lemon is an acidic fruit which
is extremely beneficial for your health
but it has to be taken almost as a
medicine when i consume lemon i make a
half a glass of lemon juice
plain i can either put water or
sparkling water or fresh coconut water
and i drink that once a week
it's a major boost for your immune
system
what do you want to drink that new pure
as a meal
eight o'clock in the morning then i wake
up to one o'clock two o'clock in the
afternoon they have regular lunches yeah
yeah because i know what i mean we know
water is so important but getting the
water the enough enough water into the
system by itself sometimes it could be
daunting so i myself i like to put um
lemon a whole lemon into the water and a
little bit of uh just a little bit of
honey and i'll drink a lot of water this
way what do you think i don't i i highly
recommend you don't do that no
no lemon no hand you know nothing just
water just water gotta get used to your
drink if anything drink coconut water
fresh coconut water don't get the one in
the box so you can or something like
that they usually are not that good yeah
but the better if we can add access to
fresh coconut great if not just regular
water okay you know i just feel healthy
so that we can do energy like this every
10 years yeah absolutely yes
and next time we got we got to make it
you know i've been down there if you're
going to visit if i'm we got to do one
in person if you're ever in chicago i
don't know if in the future you plan on
being in chicago we can bring you
actually in the studio or if i'm there
in california hopefully we can meet in
person do the interview in person next
time how's that sound yeah
uh so just a few more questions before
we uh conclude uh and this is just a
comment on you know it's it's really
tragic it's sad because you have 70
percent of uh us here in america
that are obese are overweight you have
this is the first generation of kids not
expected to outlive their parents you
know you have um you know
people on multiple cocktail of
medications you know what i mean one one
in i believe it's one in two males
suspected have cancer one in three
females uh it's just chronic diseases
it's just an epidemic explode we
prescribe more drugs but we have more
sick people it doesn't make sense and
nobody the majority of people the
healthcare system is not talking about
you know the food you know and most
people don't link the food that they put
it put into their body to the disease
and everything that's happening because
the system is not set up like that
correct hippocrates
the father of medicine
said that let by food be thy medicine
medicine that medicine be that food but
nobody does that you know i do yeah
it's it's crazy yeah so this is so
important we want to stress this you
know uh this fact about food you know
get your food right you know this is
going to be tremendous for having an
impact on your health once again the
book is available on amazon i highly
recommend your listeners to check it out
you know it's the best thing you can do
for your health yeah so you don't drink
alcohol
no you don't eat uh i i believe i'm not
if i was i read the book um years ago
pork i don't eat pork you don't need
pork okay
uh i don't think when they say that i
recommend people don't do it
okay i personally don't eat red meat you
know maybe chicken once a month yeah a
couple of months you know
yeah so we we we end up uh we shouldn't
eat that much meat i mean is over
consumption of meat but you're you're
not
you don't restrict yourself once in a
while you'll you'll also eat meat right
chicken like you just said
taste for it yeah i just i mean the
taste of it doesn't mean but yes it's on
the diet okay if you want to eat it
what was he carlos gracie jr was talking
about something about taking on the
attributes of when you eat red meat you
know this let's say you eat the the meat
of an animal that is aggressive this
will make you more aggressive this was
the philosophy something like that is
there something to that
uh no i'm not sure exactly what it meant
for that uncle you know the idea of
being a red meat he himself did not meet
i'm going to talk about uncle his son i
was talking about his son yeah yeah
yeah if you need to you know
eat the meat of a lion you're going to
be aggressive as a lion but not sure
exactly what he meant yeah but he
probably is an animal when it's going to
be slaughtered there to a stress or very
you know tense and stress yeah all that
sheer kind of stuff maybe that's what it
meant yeah something like that yeah by
eating that kind of meat i mean you just
might who knows what kind of uh you know
residuals are going to go in there and
you're going to be assimilating that
kind of stuff so so you have a reason
you're better off not eating red meat i
agree with that so you have um
no pork no smoking no drinking eating
good food having a big family i mean
um you know
in islam we're allowed to have up to
four wives i don't know if you've uh
so but you have to take care of them all
individually they have to have their own
place you have to you know monetary take
care of them it's not like you know
they're all in the same you know but
yeah so this is a response a huge
responsibility but then i just see the
similarities you know i see much there
you know when you
you know you're yourself you have 10
kids also
a big family is it 10 kids or 11 now
yeah your father had uh between him and
them two thirty
yeah that had nine of because of 21.
yeah so and i and i would see i would
see like you know quotations from your
father he was he would mention god are
these
were these actual his words you know
whenever there would be something about
the creator about god
well my father was a man of faith he
believed there was a definite creator
out there that run the universe for sure
but uh yeah
not a church going man but yeah a strong
a firm believer on the creator yeah yeah
this was something i mean my my family's
from the heart of europe bosnia you've
been you've been in different places in
europe right have you ever been to like
croatia serbia bosnia anywhere around
there
okay
oh this is a pla you know put on your
to-do list but it's interesting this is
where you know the the roots there they
were also the people my uh
tradition the the um bosnian people they
were also ones who believed in one god
the creator they didn't go to the
churches or they believed in jesus but
not as a literal god or son of god and
when when islam came it fit like a glove
the pure monotheism only worship in the
creator not the creation then they
accepted it so and then all these other
you know it was the belief in just one
and only one god and being morally
upright so you see this you know this
from yourself and your the family not i
mean we all have people in our family
who do opposite to many of the things
but uh it seems like there's this good
moral code this compass and also many of
these things it's very very uh very
refreshing to see especially in a day
and age like this where you know it's
all sorts of madness and crazy and no
discipline willpower is out the window
and people are just following their
desires and passions and sinking like a
sinking ship
yeah right immediate pleasure that kind
of stuff that's not good yeah take a
long term on everything yeah
so let me uh let's end with this you
talked about spiritual uh evolving
spiritually and again i just wanted to
do something different to show uh
people can go back and see many of your
other interviews for much more of the
history and whatnot but um i think a lot
of the audience we have a variety of
different people from all over the world
i think they would just really
appreciate this next video just to get
your reaction just to you know for a
minute to tell us uh what kind of
music do you think this is what does it
sound like you know just whatever you
think uh from listening to this for one
minute
[Music]
guidelines i guess
ultimately that's what every religion i
guess has
as a goal is to inspire its followers to
do what's what's best and do the right
thing so i think somewhere in there they
all kind of connect
going for the same thing it's nice it's
grand master horry and gracie again
really nice to reunite with you and have
you on the program and again the book
now very important
self-defense being able to defend
yourself you find yourself in such a
vulnerable situation like you saw the
father and son the guy knocks both of
them out you know and the antidote for
that is getting educated
in gracie brazilian jiu jitsu and then
you put your as we have a saying you tie
your camel then you put your trust in
god right
yeah have faith
yes yes
and two more things if you don't mind
number one is that people that want to
hear more stories about the grace they
should check out graciemuseum.com
crazymuseum.com that's one it's a
virtual museum that you can do a 360
tour and that's really interesting and
of course the book until october 5th is
on sale on amazon 25 off i highly
recommend that as well and if you want
to be healthy the gracie diet check it
out thank you so much again it's a honor
to be with you again and hopefully god
willing we can meet up again soon
thank you very much again god bless you
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you so much all right